ein symbol für den atomausstieg
das kernkraftwerk zwentendorf in der
nähe von wien vor fast 40 jahren gebaut
ist es nie in betrieb gewesen
stattdessen zieht es touristen aus ganz
europa an
wo sonst kann man sich ein atomkraftwerk
von innen anschauen ohne
sicherheitsauflagen und ohne gefahr
durch radioaktive strahlung seit dem
reaktorunglück in fukushima ist die
atomkraft umstritten wie nie die
besucher können sich hier selbst ein
bild von der technik machen
in die reaktorhülle könnte man in einem
aktiven atomkraftwerk nicht einfach so
rein spazieren
denn hier findet normalerweise die
kernreaktion statt
die großen becken wären mit wasser
geflutet um die brennstäbe zu kühlen
eine halbe milliarde euro hat der bau
des kraftwerks gekostet als es fertig
war entschieden sich die österreicher
per volksentscheid gegen die atomkraft
blick in den geöffneten reaktor
normalerweise liegt der unter einer
meterdicken betonschicht nicht
nachvollziehbar diese weite diese tiefe
liebe drollig vorstellt dass das alles
verstrahlt ist da kann man sich
vorstellen was da alles dranhängt und
sowas auch mal zurück zu bewundern
der reaktor hier ist baugleich mit dem
in fukushima hat jedoch nie strom
erzeugt anders als ein kraftwerk das am
netz ist
es ist hier eine erhöhte strahlung im
normalbetrieb eines kernkraftwerks
vorhanden
würde man den deckel den
reaktordruckbehältern die brennelemente
während drinnen dann wäre die strahlung
extrem hoch normalerweise wird das aber
nur gemacht
während der revisionsarbeiten wenn das
reaktorbecken mit wasser gefüllt ist
neben dem reaktor sind auch mehrere
originale uranbrennstäbe zu sehen
das atomkraftwerk sollte rund zwei
millionen haushalte in der region mit
strom versorgen
nach mehreren schleusen gelangt man
direkt unter die brennstäbe des reaktors
auf dieser raum wären einem aktiven
kernkraftwerk geflutet staunen bei den
besuchern
es ist unglaublich was der mensch
imstande ist zu schaffen eigentlich also
wenn ich mir das so anderem mit den
rohren systemen verkabelungen das ist
beeindruckend
auf der anderen seite auch wieder ein
bisschen beängstigend wie man denkt okay
das ist das einzige atomkraftwerk wo man
rein kann als mensch wahrscheinlich für
immer
und das ist auch wieder die kehrseite
von der metalle
österreich gehört zu den eu ländern die
keine atomkraft selbst erzeugen
die energie kommt zu zwei dritteln aus
erneuerbaren quellen wie zum beispiel
wasserkraft obwohl die meisten bürger
kernenergie ablehnen
rund 15 prozent des benötigten stroms
muss importiert werden
auch atomstrom aus deutschland oder
tschechien
umweltschützer kritisieren dass seit
langem atomkraft ist eine gescheiterte
technologie der vergangenheit die nie
wettbewerbsfähiger die niemals fähig war
und die zusätzliche diese ganzen
sicherheits und atommüll probleme hat
das heißt es ist einfach ein auslaufen
der dinosaurier der vergangenheit denn
kein privater investor ohne massive
subventionierung durch die steuerzahler
noch geld reinsteckt im akw zwentendorf
das nie atomstrom produziert hat ist die
schaltzentrale einer art technikmuseum
computertechnologie aus den 80er jahren
und telefone mit wählscheibe atomkraft
ja oder nein
die bürger in österreich haben diese
umstrittene frage schon 1978 beantwortet
ganz knapp gewannen die gegner der
kernenergie